En medio de una de las crisis políticas,
económicas, sociales e, incluso, judiciales,
más importantes de la última década, el
país más extenso y poblado de toda América
Latina se prepara para celebrar elecciones
generales el próximo mes de Octubre.
Es entonces, cuando el actual presidente de
la República Federativa de Brasil, Michel
Temer, deberá hacerse a un lado y dejar un
cargo que asumió sin elecciones mediante.
Sí, así es.
Brasil es un país democrático desde 1988,
pero en 2016, ante graves acusaciones de irregularidades
y corrupción, un juicio político, un impeachment
resuelto con un abrumador voto a favor tanto
en la Cámara de Diputados como en el Senado,
removió del cargo a la entonces Presidenta
y líder del Partido de los Trabajadores,
Dilma Rousseff.
(Tras la expulsión de la presidenta Rousseff
del Palacio de la Aurora, la residencia oficial
del Presidente de Brasil, el cargo pasó a
manos de su vicepresidente, Michel Temer,
que… la verdad no ha sido, precisamente,
el presidente más popular.
Durante estos dos años al frente de Brasil.
Temer se ha enfrentado a una ola de descontento
social, a grandes brotes de violencia y a
una intensa crisis económica.)
[Vamos, en otras palabras, a día de hoy casi
podemos decir que Temer tiene más probabilidades
de ir convocado con la selección brasileña
de fútbol que de regresar algún día al
palacio presidencial, como inquilino.]
Pero, amigos, ahora el momento de la verdad
ha llegado.
Con un nuevo presidente, un nuevo vicepresidente,
un nuevo Congreso, una nueva mayoría en el
Senado y una nueva elección o reelección
de gobernadores, Brasil debe escoger un nuevo
rumbo.
Pero… ¿Qué es, exactamente, lo que se
está jugando Brasil?
Pues…. Antes de responder a esta pregunta…
necesitamos haceros una advertencia:
si únicamente tuviéramos en cuenta las circunstancias
políticas, a día de hoy, el futuro de Brasil
parecería menos prometedor, que la carrera política de Jeb Bush.
[Sí, ese candidato que se gastó 14 millones
de dólares para lograr un 2,5% de los votos
en el caucus de Iowa. Algo más de $2.400
por cada persona que le dio su voto]
Veréis, me explico.
El candidato favorito entre los brasileños,
el candidato que lideraba todas las encuestas
y que ganaría hoy las elecciones, tiene un
problema: Y es que, está ni más ni menos
que en chirona, en la cárcel.
Hablamos, como no, de Lula Da Silva, presidente
de Brasil entre 2003 y 2011, histórico dirigente
del Partido de los Trabajadores y uno de los
líderes políticos brasileños más importantes
de las últimas décadas
Ahora bien, puede que alguno os estéis preguntando…
pero ¿Qué pasó? ¿Cómo una figura tan
importante ha terminado en prisión?
Pues… ni más ni menos que… [seguro, seguro
que lo acertáis]: Por corrupción.
(En 2015 un tribunal del estado de Parana
abrió una investigación sobre un posible
caso de corrupción que involucraba al ex
presidente.
La operación, conocida como Lava Jato, determinó
que Lula Da Silva había recibido sobornos
a cambio de favorecer desde el gobierno mediante
contratos de empresas públicas a compañías
como Odebrecht, entre otras constructoras.)
De esta forma, quien fue conocido, especialmente,
por sus programas sociales, que según se
dice permitieron sacar de la pobreza a 50
millones de brasileños [Aunque la realidad
es un poco diferente] cumple hoy una pena
de prisión de 12 años por corrupción.
Y sí, a pesar de estar entre rejas, con una
condena firme por corrupción, Lula ha seguido
siendo el favorito de los brasileños para
el cargo de Presidente de la República.
Cosas de la política…
[Por cierto, por si no lo sabéis o no habéis
caído. Lula no solo está condenado por corrupción,
sino que la propia Dilma Rousseff, la presidenta
que fue expulsada mediante Impeachment fue
la propia sucesora de Lula.
Vamos, que más que un gobierno, casi que
parecía el atraco a un banco.
[Por cierto, hay una serie de Netflix, bastante
interesante sobre todo esto, Túnel de Corrupción.
No os la perdáis]
Pero, ahora bien, no penséis que todo
esto fue solo cosa de Lula. Paran nada.
Lo cierto es que
Brasil es un país que tiene un serio problema
con la corrupción.
De hecho, creo que podemos decir hay tres
cosas que principalmente frenan el despegue
de ese coloso: la violencia, la burocracia
y la corrupción generalizada.
Invertir en Brasil no es una tarea nada sencilla.
Y tal vez esto es lo que explica los difíciles
momentos por los que está atravesando el país.
(BRASIL: ¿LA ETERNA DECEPCIÓN?)
Brasil, no levanta cabeza. Por cada año bueno
hay por los menos 3 años malos… y así
no se puede.
De esta forma, un país que podría ser una
próspera potencia, padece hoy una enorme
fragilidad económica, política y social.
Los últimos años son buena
prueba de ello.
Fijaos, Los dos anteriores presidentes fueron
implicados en casos de corrupción; Lula Da
Silva y Dilma Rousseff. El actual presidente,
Michel Temer tampoco se libra, tiene muchas
sospechas a sus espaldas.
(Luego… está el problema de la violencia
que ha crecido bastante, hasta unos niveles
más que preocupantes…
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo que estamos
hablando, en 2017 se produjeron más de 60.000
homicidios en Brasil, esto supone más que
la suma de los que se producen en Afganistán
y en Irak juntos.)
Por otro lado, la pobreza y el desempleo han
repuntado en los últimos años al compás
de una economía que no carbura, entre otras
cosas porque el país permanece excluido en
gran medida del comercio internacional por
su apuesta proteccionista y burocrática.
[ Qué ¿Son políticas que no funcionan?
¿Y qué? ¿Cual es el problema? La prosperidad
no llegará a todos… pero anda que a los
políticos….]
En fin, todo este desastre es lo que explica
hechos como este que se ha podido ver en todo
el planeta:
(“Un voraz incendio destruye el Museo Nacional
de Brasil. El museo, que albergaba 20 millones
de piezas incluidos fósiles y momias, no
contaba con sistema contra incendios”. Europa Press)
Amigos, esto es Brasil. Sin embargo, esperad
un momento. Las elecciones pueden suponer
un cambio de rumbo… o tal vez no.
Atentos.
(LA COMPETICIÓN MÁS IMPORTANTE)
Durante los últimos 22 años… 2 partidos
políticos se han repartido el gobierno de
Brasil: el partido de los trabajadores, el
partido de Lula Da Silva y el Partido De la
Socialdemocracia Brasileña, el PSDR.
Ahora de cara a estas próximos comicios… viendo
los resultados… lo normal, no sé, sería
esperar que estos dos partidos trataran de
dar un giro de 180 grados, ¿No os parece?
Sin embargo… nada de eso.
Por un lado, el Partido de los Trabajadores
ha tratado por todos los medios de presentar
como candidato a Lula Da Silva… Ya, total,
que esté en la cárcel…
[Vamos a ver, no os equivoqueis, que eso de
aceptar sobornos, oye lo mismo supuso un enorme
sacrificio para el bueno de Lula. Seguro,
seguro que os podéis hacer una idea.]
Pero… en serio… no se trata de ensañarse
con Lula… desgraciadamente la política
brasileña es así.
De todas formas, finalmente, el pasado 31 de agosto
de 2018 el Tribunal Electoral lo confirmó:
de ninguna manera, Lula no podría ser candidato.
Pero dada la línea que ha seguido el partido…
creo que no podemos hablar de renovación
ni de cambio ¿No os parece?
(Por otro lado, el PSDB ha presentado a Geraldo
Alckmin… y aquí sí, sorpresa. El candidato
empezó la campaña con un discurso, digamos
que centrado en sacar a Brasil del atolladero.
Para ello anunció no solo que reduciría
la carga fiscal y mejoraría los incentivos
a la inversión, sino que, incluso, tomaría
como referencia las políticas que a principio
de los 90 puso sobre la mesa el expresidente
Fernando Henrique Cardoso, el protagonista
tal vez de la mayor etapa de prosperidad y
cambio del Brasil en décadas.)
Suena bien, ¿Verdad?
Pues… amigos, no corramos tanto, Brasil
es Brasil… De tal manera que no han tardado
en aparecer noticias como esta:
("Fiscales brasileños acusan a candidato
presidencial Alckmin por recibir fondos de
Odebrecht. América Economía.)
Ya sabéis, siempre en la misma línea, en el mismo negocio.
Con esta panorama creo que a nadie le cueste
entender porque los brasileños están perdiendo
la confianza en su sistema político.
¿Y qué suele ocurrir cuando la sociedad
pierde esa confianza? Exacto… es el momento
idóneo para movimientos populistas o radicales.
Y eso, amigos… es precisamente lo que parece
que está ocurriendo.
En este caso, un militar retirado, un candidato
con un plan de medidas drásticas, Jair Bolsonaro
se ha convertido en la gran sorpresa de estas
elecciones.
(Y eso que Bolsonaro es conocido por frases
y planteamientos tan reprobables como estos:
"No voy a combatir ni a discriminar, pero
si veo a dos hombres besándose en la calle,
les voy a pegar." Jair Bolsonaro
“El error de la dictadura fue torturar y
no matar." Jair Bolsonaro)
Veréis, a día de hoy, lo más probable es
que pasen a segunda vuelta, el propio Jair
Bolsonaro y Fernando Haddad, el sustituto
de Lula Da Silva.
(La situación ahora mismo es tan complicada,
que en el marco de la enorme ola de violencia
que registra Brasil, durante un acto de campaña,
Bolsonaro recibió una puñalada que le ha
producido graves lesiones… lo que evidentemente
le ha obligado a ser hospitalizado y a continuar
su campaña, principalmente, por redes sociales.
El motivo de tal polémica no es otro que
las propias características de este ultra
y radical político.
Duro, defensor de la pena de muerte y de la
militarización de la política, sus críticos
le tachan de ser xenófobo, homófobo, autoritario
y un auténtico peligro para la democracia
brasileña.)
Ahora bien, viendo todo esto, ¿Qué explica el fuerte auge
de este candidato en las encuestas? ¿Se debe
su extraordinaria intención de voto exclusivamente
a un voto crítico e indignado? ¿Es algo
así como una moda pasajera?
Pues..., ojo, porque en el despegue de Bolsonaro
tiene mucho que ver el voto evangélico...
hasta tal punto, que puede que no estemos,
simplemente, ante un voto de protesta sino
tal vez ante una tendencia mucho más sólida.
Veréis, Brasil es un país muy religioso.
Por ejemplo, gracias a su tamaño es el país
con más católicos de todo el planeta. Unos
123 millones de personas profesan esta religión.
Sin embargo, en los últimas décadas está
creciendo con fuerza la población evangélica.
Según el último censo, los evangélicos
suponen ya el 20% de la población del país,
una de cada cinco personas, más de 40 millones de personas.
Y por lo general, suelen ser un poquito más
conservadores y activistas de tal modo...
que ya os podéis imaginar quién es su candidato
favorito.
Sí, asi es.
La intención de voto del señor Bolsonaro
entre la población evangélica es entre
8 y 10 puntos superior a su apoyo entre el
conjunto de brasileños.
Fijaos:
(“En Brasil necesitamos un macho como él.
Defenderá todos los valores y principios
de la familia cristiana”. Silas Malafaia,
uno de los pastores más influyentes de Brasil.)
En fin amigos, ¿Veremos un cambio de verdad
en Brasil o continuará el duopolio que ha
regido los destinos del país durante los
últimos 22 años? ¿Dará la campanada el
radical Jair Bolsonaro? ¿Algún otro candidato
nuevo no alineado con los dos grandes partidos?
Muy pronto lo sabremos. De momento todo apunta
a nueva nueva victoria en segunda vuelta del
Partido de los Trabajadores, el Partido de
Lula Da Silva y Dilma Rousseff.
La pregunta que nos podemos hacer es, ¿Realmente
es otro gobierno del Partido de los Trabajadores
lo mejor para Brasil? Porque, Amigos, si algo
está claro es que Brasil necesita un cambio
de rumbo… Y no parece que más de lo mismo
pueda suponer realmente un cambio.
Pero ahora turno para tí, ¿De 1 al 5, qué
opinión tienes de Lula Da Silva? Déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Por cierto muchas gracias a Sebastian Morales
Forte por ayudarnos a preparar este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.